daily room cleaning is on the line for
hundreds of Nevada hotels it was
required the beginning of the pandemic
now a Senate bill could not require it
and Hospitality workers believe it will
impact their job security agents now
reporter Ryan Matthey shows us The
Divide
to bring you up to speed sb4 here
brought those heightened cleaning
standards to prevent the spread of
covid-19 within hotels but unlike other
pandemic laws this one did not have an
end date then comes SB 441 this bill
could repeal everything that this bill
requires but according to the union that
represents thousands of workers in the
hotels just behind me this bill is a bad
look for Vegas
it's called the last remaining law of
the emergency covet era they don't want
housekeeping Nevada legislatures met
Monday in a very different environment
than in 2020. it worked then but it
doesn't work now they point to the
metrics used to measure virus
transmission when this bill was passed
that are no longer in effect and the
rate at which our guests are declining
daily housekeeping is is nearly double
what it was before the pandemic MGM
Resorts testified that over 40 percent
of its guests declined daily
housekeeping within the past year either
because they're working getting extra
rest or simply don't want strangers in
their room we're not going to stop
cleaning rooms and even if they wanted
to Nevada Resorts Association lobbyist
Billy vasiliadis adds thousands of guest
room attendant positions across Southern
Nevada are vacant we're trying to hire
people again the entire industry
throughout the United States is
desperately trying to hire staff for in
Hospitality this is a bad look for Las
Vegas but The Culinary Union which
represents 60 000 hotel workers across
Nevada argues with a lesser requirement
to clean comes a lesser need for hotels
to keep them on staff Ted Papa George is
secretary treasurer the companies call
them green programs but the reality is
it was about reducing labor and cutting
costs what the testifying Resorts and
lobbyists deny but the union says if
passed workers will be left less safe
while cleaning alone the idea that these
working women many of them most of them
women of color are to be alone in this
struggle and left alone by the
legislature we're not going to accept
that